- Where is Dan?
(audience cheering)
Oh, hi, Dan!
- Hi Kelly.
- Hi!
(audience cheering)
- Keepin' context with the rookie moves
that we're talkin' about, I got a problem,
I think everybody's got
it in their department,
but I got one that hits close to home,
and it's the one upper,
and everybody's got that,
you make this car stop
and maybe see some drugs
and your guy tells ya,
"Yeah, well I see drugs
"and guns and this and
that," so your always
gettin' one upped and I get this issue
that hits close to home
'cause it's my brother
that there's a huge one up factor
that no matter what I do
and what big save I may have
or what I do, everyone always
says, "Well, what's your
"brother up to and what's he doin?"
I'm like, "You guys just see
what I just did back there?"
- Is he a cop too?
- No, he's pretended to be a cop
and he's pretended to be a firefighter.
- Is he an actor, a scripted
fight, he's an actor?
- I guess you could call it an actor.
(Kelly laughing)
He does do movies,
he's tried to--
- Was in he in something
better than "From Justin to Kelly?"
(Kelly laughing)
(audience cheering)
- That's our game!
That's our game.
Oh, John Cena everybody!
(audience cheering)
Oh my God!
- Dan!
- John Cena's
your brother, okay!
- Dan, what the!
(audience cheering)
(Kelly laughing)